but your dad's LAPD yeah how was that
growing up after your records are now
charting oh you're walking in with you
hey what's that's your kid yeah that was
the biggest time of his life I you know
because he could get free records from
me so and then hand him out to all the
juvenile delinquents man and that was
[Music]
what's going on over here man who was
like it's exactly how it worked why
being the neighborhood right exactly
radical one over here it is oh they were
glad to get the record so it was like of
course I couldn't imagine I would not
believe that cop in one bit yeah you're
yeah your case
that's me and that's seeing the last
name saying oh okay
[Laughter]
and it was always